while putin's war has inspired most
americans to put aside their political
differences and unite behind the people
of ukraine it has not stopped some
progressive pundits from tying the war
to domestic issues
today the average gas price in america
hit an all-time record high of over four
dollars per gallon i'm willing to pay
four dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla perhaps
if you let the market work in this
respect people will feel pain they'll
take a second look at that ford f-450
gigantoid truck we have to move to clean
energy solutions clean is in the end
where we should be so that we don't find
ourselves in this position again
stephen colbert willing to pay 15
dollars for gas i'm sure he is on that
multi-million dollar salary john kerry
also saying the mass refugee crisis
happening in ukraine right now is
nothing compared to our future climate
change problems
if you think migration has been a
problem in europe from the syrian war or
even from what we see now
when you see 100 million people for whom
the entire
food production capacity has collapsed
beets never let a crisis go to waste it
is all about climate
yes it is and you know what they're
being honest
they welcome the pain they want the
prices and now they have a they get to
wrap it in a so-called patriotic duty
it's like their new mask or the new
black square it's their new
opportunity to virtue signal with the
ukrainian flag while then saying oh by
the way gas prices are at six bucks and
it's all putin's fault and as a result
you should now you should now buy into
our green new fantasies when it's those
very fantasies that created the kind of
dependency and conditions we're in right
now which have helped lead to that so
it's it is exactly who they are and what
they believe cassie that's right they
want you to pay more look we don't have
to be paying 15 for gas or you know
right now it's like four or five dollars
but you don't have to pay that
we can embargo russian oil and unleash
domestic energy that is not great
midterm messaging there from colbert
right well you know kayla the the
liberal elite echo chamber is
definitely loud and it's drowning out
these cries and complaints from
americans who are saying i can't afford
your policy i don't want your policy
your policy is crippling my pocketbook
my business my community our local
economy and to your point about the
midterms they will pay for that because
all of this is at the end of the day for
democrats just them trying to get their
policies through as pete mentioned
whether it was kovid and now here we are
with um with gas and foreign policy this
is all in the big picture about getting
their socialist agenda through and
americans aren't buying it because it's
hurting us and that's where they're
going to feel the pain there's a poll
just out i think wall street journal
within the last day or so 50 of
americans say inflation is my number one
concern right now and as long as
democrats try and make this about
something else they will lose uh not
just the hearts and minds but the the
votes of the american people as well no
doubt meanwhile uh joy reid has some
thoughts on all this let's listen oh
good
church of ukraine has revealed a pretty
radical disparity in how human
ukrainians look and feel to western
media compared to their browner and
blacker counterparts with some reporters
using very telling comparisons in their
analyses of the war
i mean carly why like
i can't believe i have to explain this
um but this is a war about an attack on
43 innocent 43 million innocent people
being attacked by a former kgb madman
with uh nuclear weapons that's what this
is about and there was also a uh similar
discussion that gayle king had on her
show where they started to talk about
how ukrainian refugees are being treated
better than people who are
crossing our southern border trying to
turn our make our country seem racist
and unwelcoming will then explain
how we were so welcoming when afghan
refugees were coming into our country
not everything has to be about race and
not everything has to be about america's
evil and this war is certainly an
example of not fitting the bill on that
regard but for liberals of course
everything has to be about trump let's
listen to whoopi goldberg
you know bonehead was
yeah was had been president and i say
what i said last time no there wouldn't
have been any issue because that guy
would have handed
ukraine over to the russians
except we had a four-year experiment of
president trump and there was no
invasion right last time i checked this
invasion happened under someone else's
watch and that is just one more example
to me as well of maxima or minimalizing
what is occurring in that situation and
then we have that same explosive
hyperbolic rhetoric about what happens
here so we have msnbc host chuck todd
saying that he was stunned by when the
president gave his state of the union
address his failure to essentially
equate the fight for democracy and
freedom abroad to connect it with the
fight for democracy and freedom at home
probably because because there is
nothing similar about the two to your
point carly i think it's pretty clear
that one is facing an existential crisis
minute by minute with a potentially for
esc where the potential for escalation
into a global war and then one is about
democrats crying about republicans
rampant um suppression of votes i mean
it's absolutely ridiculous to think that
the connection of those two would be in
any way logical but that's what you get
from the left that's what you get from
the mainstream media yeah i mean we end
where we began never let a crisis go to
waste i mean that's what it's all about
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now